travis kourtney kardashian turned 42 on
sunday
and to celebrate travis barker shared
one shocking video
yeah that that's court sucking on
travis's thumb
the blink 182 drummer shared the clip to
instagram
alongside the caption quote i [ __ ]
love you
you're a blessing to this world happy
birthday courtney
i love it travis also posted this
smooched up snap
their fireside cuddle sesh a corner
makeout
a pic of her legs a booty shot some
hand-holding
and yeah again that thumb sucking video
the musician also sent court an
over-the-top arrangement of tulips and
gardenias
her two favorite flowers and the whole
thing
pretty much took up the reality star's
entire entryway
and yes those are flowers hanging from
the ceiling
the birthday girl showed off the
romantic gesture on her insta story on
saturday
tagging travis alongside a black heart
emoji
and writing my entire house smells yummy
this is such a dream come true even
courtney's sis
kim kardashian was shook by the gift
okay i just walked into the most
gorgeous
flower arrangement you can smell the
entire house
this is so beautiful i've never seen
anything like this
happy birthday court kim honored court
with a slideshow of throwback pics on
instagram
writing in part quote i love you to the
end of time
and beyond i love that she also sent the
push founder a birthday card wishing her
a happy 41st birthday when she
actually turned 42 which court
hilariously shared on her instagram
story
so kim thinks i'm 41 so
i guess last year really didn't count
yeah so that happened and kim she
reposted the clip acknowledging her
mistake
writing my bad quartz x scott disick
also wished her a happy b day sharing
this snap to his instagram story
and writing happy birthday to the best
mom a child could ask for
and some more i'm just like living life
and whatever happens happens as for
court's relationship with travis
the two seem to have gotten way more
serious since they first went public
with their relationship earlier this
year
travis got the keeping up with the
kardashians star's name tattooed on his
chest
and a source recently told et that they
are so
into each other quote they act like
teenagers who are in love
their chemistry is crazy and everyone
around them can see how cute they are
together and how happy they make each
other
their relationship has been fun easy
going and natural
and is the real deal
[Music]
you